el partido demócrata de Estados Unidos
retiene el control del senado tras la
victoria de catering Cortez masto en
Nevada en la cámara de representantes
los republicanos necesitan siete escaños
de los 20 que quedan por conocerse para
alcanzar la mayoría
las fuerzas ucranianas han recuperado el
control de más de 60 localidades en la
región de gerson tras La retirada de las
tropas rusas de la orilla occidental del
río nyaper vuelo dimmer selensky
denunció que el ejército de Moscú
destruyó la infraestructura crítica de
la ciudad de jerson antes de abandonarla
analizamos en esta edición
las autoridades del tigre y el Gobierno
Federal de Etiopía firmaron la paz tras
dos años de guerra el acuerdo permite la
llegada de ayuda humanitaria a la región
afectada por una grave problema de
hambruna debido al bloqueo del conflicto
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en Estados Unidos
porque el partido demócrata mantiene el
control del senado tras la victoria de
catering Cortez masto en el estado de
Nevada en la composición actual los
demócratas cuentan con 50 escaños y los
republicanos con 49 Todavía queda un
escaño al senado por decidirse en la
segunda vuelta del estado de Georgia del
6 de diciembre pero aunque luego ganarán
los republicanos y la cámara alta
quedará dividida en 50 a 50 el voto de
la vicepresidenta cámara Harris
desempataría y otorgaría la mayoría a
los demócratas Cristóbal vá nuestro
corresponsal en Washington con los
detalles
Catherine Cortés la primera mujer latina
en haber sido electa al senado de
Estados Unidos Hace seis años Fue
reelecta tras una ajustada Carrera
contra el republicano Adam quien fue
apoyado además por Donald Trump su
Victoria lleva entonces a que los
demócratas aseguren las 50 sillas
necesarias para lograr la mayoría en la
cámara alta teniendo en cuenta que el
voto de desempate lo decide la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris la victoria
de Cortés se terminó definiendo en el
condado de Clark condado donde está la
ciudad de Las Vegas y donde todavía se
están contando más votos con esta
Victoria los demócratas ya no dependen
de la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
al senado en Georgia y además tendrán el
poder en los próximos años de confirmar
jueces federales y otros oficiales
públicos y abrir sus propias
investigaciones sin depender de la
cámara del representantes al respecto el
líder
en una rueda de prensa que esta era una
victoria de la agenda del partido
demócrata y de los estadounidenses que
se opusieron a candidatos extremistas
respaldados por Donald Trump
como avanzamos en los titulares el
control de la cámara de representantes
todavía no está decidido quedan 20
escaños por conocerse y los republicanos
solo necesitan a 7 para alcanzar la
mayoría un control republicano de la
cámara baja implicaría que la actual
presidenta de este órgano legislativo
hablamos de la demócrata Nancy pelosi
sería reemplazada en el cargo sin
embargo pero se declaró que pase lo que
pase no tiene intención de dejar el
congreso repasamos su perfil con el
siguiente informe de Andrés granadillo
una demócrata que desata amores y odios
Nancy pelosi la hasta ahora presidenta
de la cámara de representantes ha sido
pieza clave en las iniciativas de los
dirigentes de su partido
es un día feliz para nuestro país porque
Joe biden es un unificador porque está
decidido a unir a la gente
ejerció como líder de la cámara
inicialmente de 2007 a 2011 en 2010
ayudó a aprobar el famoso plan de salud
de Obama conocido como Obama Care en
2019 cuando volvió a liderazgo de la
cámara fue fundamental en los planes de
ayuda económica para los estadounidenses
afectados por la pandemia de Kobe 19 y
decisiva en los proyectos de Joe biden
Pero ha sido una piedra en el zapato
para su principal opositor el ex
presidente de Donald Trump a quien le
inició dos juicios políticos con el
ánimo de destituirlo el primero en 2019
por acusaciones de retención indebida de
ayuda militar a Ucrania y otro en 2021
por incitar el ataque del 6 de enero en
el Capitolio
hoy se produce un vergonzoso salto a
nuestra democracia sin embargo no puede
isodirnos de nuestra responsabilidad de
validar la elección de Joe biden Harris
velocí también ha sido fuerte en la
política exterior en agosto de este año
enfureció a China tras visitar la
diputada isla de Taiwán ser la cara más
reconocida de la cámara de
representantes le ha causado también
problemas de seguridad en el ataque del
Capitolio la masa irrumpió en su oficina
mientras gritaba queremos a Nancy
Asimismo el 28 de octubre en su casa en
San Francisco un hombre atacó
brutalmente a su esposo con un martillo
mientras decía donde está Nancy la
presidenta podría perder su cargo cuando
se defina quién será la mayoría de la
cámara de representantes vamos ahora con
noticias relativas a la invasión rusa de
Ucrania precisamente porque Ucrania
restablece su control sobre la ciudad de
gerson tras La retirada de las tropas
rusas recordemos que el viernes las
fuerzas especiales de kiev fueron las
primeras en entrar a la ciudad
abandonada por los rusos ayer ingresaron
día policías autoridades ucranianas
empezó a llegar ayuda humanitaria Y es
que según el presidente ucraniano
bolodimirselenski el ejército de Moscú
destruyó la infraestructura crítica de
la ciudad para analizar el desarrollo de
la guerra contamos ahora con Fernando
cocho analista de inteligencia Y
seguridad internacional Fernando buenos
días Le quiero empezar preguntando por
una breve análisis de A qué responde La
retirada rusa de gerson
bueno no sabemos lo que tiene Putin en
la cabeza Pero hay tres posibilidades
que están barajando en todos los
análisis de inteligencia Y seguridad uno
que abandona gerson como una especie de
Berlín de los años 40 para ser la ciudad
a partir de la cual se pueda negociar
con Ucrania un fin de la guerra bajo la
presión de Estados Unidos China India
entre otros una segunda variante sería
que se ha refugiado en más en el
profundo bombas Putin porque son tampoco
lo necesitaba desde el punto de vista
geoestratégico y la tercera que pretenda
dar una señal hacia Ucrania que le haga
bajar sus exigencias a la hora de una
negociación eso es lo que se está
barajando otra cosa es lo que realmente
después ocurra la semana pasada vaiden
ya estableció una línea de comunicación
constante con Putin hace unos 4 o 5 días
china e India hablaron con Putin
diciendo que eso tenía que acabar y por
otra parte la unión
europeando también que tiene que de
alguna manera negociar con con Rusia
puesto que esto se puede convertirse en
una guerra muy muy larga
y usted habla de este escenario en que
ejerzon podría ser un elemento de
negociación en qué sentido
Pues que se convirtiera algo parecido a
una frontera idílica en el que como
Corea del Norte Corea del Sur fuera una
ciudad en la que a partir de ahí se
pudiera negociar porque ambas partes
exceden algo Putin cédula una ciudad
estratégica muy importante y al mismo
tiempo recupera el valor de su posición
geoestratégica con con jerson pero había
que esperar un poco la negociaciones nos
olvidamos siempre de que los eslavos
negocen de una manera diferente al resto
del mundo o el resto de los occidentes
Si queremos el ahorro sí son muy dados a
la negociación pero continúan la batalla
continua la guerra son muy a los modelos
clásicos de closer entonces para ellos
combatir y negociar no es incompatible
mientras que para nosotros parece
difícil y respecto al segundo de los
escenarios que ustedes estaba comentando
parece que Rusia está construyendo una
línea defensiva en la orilla Oriental
del Río niéper qué sentido estratégico
tendría este río precisamente
precisamente este río el río níper la
parte oriental del río níper es la zona
más prorrosa o era la zona más por rusa
o rusofila de toda Ucrania y es una
frontera natural que siempre ha
establecido ha establecido como los
límites a partidos cuales Putin
establecería una seguridad nacional
geoestratégica por tanto La retirada
hasta el río nieper o del río níper
dividiendo a esas zonas de Ucrania
significaría también un punto de
inflexión en el que como hemos dicho
antes se pareciera salvando La distancia
es por supuesto a una Corea del Norte
Corea del Sur para una posible futura
negociación la frontera natural del río
neper siempre desde el punto de vista
estratégico desde el principio de la
guerra se estableció como la frontera
natural de lo que podría ser para Putin
la seguridad que él llama nacional y
para Ucrania toda la parte de control
incluso de salida al mar de lo que
significaría para ellos la posición
estratégica recuperada y el peso
importante que tienes que son el punto
de vista geopolítico Industrial a pesar
de que Putin ha destruido la
infraestructura críticas de esa ciudad
Fernando cocho Le agradezco mucho su
tiempo y se análisis
un placer está con vosotros Gracias
cambiamos de información vamos ahora a
la ciudad turca de Estambul donde se
produjo una explosión que causó al menos
seis muertos y 38 heridos Esta es una
noticia en desarrollo Ya esta hora se
desconocen los detalles de los hechos
pero el presidente del país receptáis
erdogan declaró que según información
preliminar parece un ataque bomba sin
embargo de momento ninguna organización
a reivindicado los hechos que tuvieron
lugar en la avenida izstical en el
centro de la ciudad en una zona
concurrida tanto por locales como
oportunistas
en primer lugar me gustaría expresar mis
condolencias a quienes murieron en el
atentado con bomba y deseo una pronta
recuperación a quienes resultaron
heridos en la avenida isquitlalo y
alrededor de las 16 y 20 de la tarde
murieron cuatro de ellas murieron en el
lugar otras dos murieron en capital
según la última información del
gobernador el número de heridos es de 53
sería un error afirmar que esto es sin
duda un ataque terrorista Pero los
primeros desarrollos y la inteligencia
inicial de mi gobernador es que huela
terrorismo los primeros hallazgos
muestran que entre la gente que huyó una
mujer ha jugado un papel
y las autoridades de la región del tigre
y el Gobierno Federal de Etiopía
firmaron un nuevo acuerdo este sábado en
Kenia para implementar la paz tras dos
años de guerra el tratado establece el
desarme de los Rebeldes y la
restauración de la autoridad Federal
sobre el tigre además ambas partes se
comprometen a permitir la llegada de
ayuda humanitaria a la región que debido
al bloqueo del conflicto está afectada
por un grave problema de hambruna
un paso más hacia la paz en Etiopía el
sábado las fuerzas Rebeldes de la región
del tigre y el gobierno de Etiopía
firmaron un acuerdo que concretes a las
etapas de la implementación de la paz
que fue pactada el 3 de noviembre en
Sudáfrica
nos dedicaremos plenamente a aplicar el
acuerdo de pretoria y esta declaración
ambas partes se comprometieron a
permitir la llegada de la muy esperada
ayuda a humanitaria al tigre y la
protección de los civiles el acuerdo
debe tener efecto inmediato y también
previa el desarme de los Rebeldes
me alienta el hecho de que ambas partes
reconozcan la necesidad de que el pueblo
de Etiopía venga de donde venga necesita
hoy asistencia humanitaria necesita
alimentos necesita medicinas necesita
que se reanuden los servicios el tigre
fue devastado por dos años de guerra
Durante los cuales la región fue aislada
por los militares hechos el conflicto
mató al menos 100.000 personas y
desplazó a millones además cientos de
miles están al borde de la hombruna en
la región
hemos sufrido una miseria incalculable
Durante los dos últimos años y seguimos
sufriendo el compromiso que asumimos hoy
es con la esperanza y las expectativas
de que el sufrimiento de nuestro pueblo
llegue a su fin y pronto
sin embargo la paz sigue siendo frágil y
ambas partes tendrán que comprometerse
en la rendición de cuentas además
eritrea el vecino de Etiopía involucrado
en el conflicto al lado del Gobierno
Federal no ha tomado parte en las
negociaciones
y cerramos en Haití porque vuelve a
fluir el suministro de gasolina y diesel
tras dos meses de escasez recordemos que
una coalición de pandillas había
bloqueado la distribución de los
combustibles en el país lo que agravó la
fuerte crisis económica y el rebrote de
cólera que deja al menos 40 muertos
por fin un respiro para los haitianos
luego de dos meses sin suministro las
estaciones de gasolina abrieron en Haití
bajo fuertes medidas de seguridad un
gran alivio para los conductores aunque
se quejan por los altos precios
impuestos por las autoridades
Quiero conseguir gasolina mejores
precios no quiero tener que ir a
buscarla en las calles donde el precio
es muy alto además la gasolina es muy
mala y podría romper el motor del auto
el 12 de septiembre la coalición de
pandillas g9 liderada por alias barbacoa
se había tomado la terminal barró
encargada del almacenamiento del 70% del
combustible del país las pandillas Se
tomaron la central luego de días de
violentas protestas tras el anuncio de
la finalización de subsidios al
combustible por parte del Primer
Ministro ají el ángel el país se
paralizó económicamente y entró en una
fuerte crisis humanitaria que
imposibilitó la distribución de agua
potable clave para combatir un rebrote
de cólera que según informó el
Ministerio de salud ha dejado más de
1700 sospechas de contagio y 40 muertes
el primer combustible que salió de la
terminal se dirigió a fábricas
hospitales y otras instituciones
públicas
por fin podemos respirar porque el país
se paralizó por la escasez de
combustible por fin Hoy podemos
encontrar algo de combustible que nos
haga felices
toda la población sintió el efecto de la
escasez de combustible porque es un
producto esencial
durante el tiempo del bloqueo el mercado
negro comerciaba la gasolina a unos 30
dólares por galón un precio que muy
pocos podían pagar
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros
[Música]